un mensaje y el mensaje es que uno puede
envejecer bien envejecer ustedes piensan
a veces que es enfermar y
lamentablemente afortunadamente no es lo
mismo
por qué es tan importante por qué es tan
importante preocuparnos del
envejecimiento porque de esto va a
depender nuestra calidad de vida y la
calidad de vida significa que podamos
correr podemos caminar podamos pensar
podamos acordarnos de que fuimos a la
cocina podamos ver el diario y aunque
tengamos que usar lentes
ya en otras
ciencias tienen investigado cómo detener
el envejecimiento o cómo recuperarlo por
ejemplo en ingeniería si ustedes tienen
un vehículo cierto un auto que se va a
oxidar ellos saben perfectamente cómo
mantenerlo para que no se deteriore
el desafío entonces de nosotros es
lograr sentirnos bien lograr vernos bien
y envejecer bien que es tener esta
energía para poder hacer las cosas que
nosotros queremos hacer
lamentablemente no hay ninguna pastilla
o tratamiento mágico en esto
de qué se trata el envejecimiento es un
proceso en que las células se van
deteriorando van perdiendo la energía y
la vitalidad esto se relaciona con la
edad pero a pesar de que empiezan los 40
años y las hormonas se empiezan a
vitorear a los 20 años
hay personas que tienen un
envejecimiento acelerado
vamos a cambiar van a cambiar nuestros
órganos ya está medido el peso de los
riñones del hígado del corazón el
cerebro cómo funcionan todos se hace más
lento y nuestra columna por ejemplo
vertebral se va a
y alterar también
donde parte donde parte este
envejecimiento en la célula y ahí les
puse es unas células bellas en 3b
unas son linfocitos hay un macrófago
tenemos la neurona
el macrófago el linfocito y esta es una
célula madre
la célula madre tiene la capacidad de
transformarse en las otras células y esa
célula madre también se va perdiendo con
el envejecimiento la célula madre es la
que nos permite regenerar nos
entonces cuáles son las causas del
envejecimiento y va a partir por un daño
mitocondrial
los radicales libres dañan la
mitocondria esto va a hacer que se
acumulen residuos tóxicos porque la
mitocondria ahí en la célula hay algunos
antioxidantes que permiten sacar los
tóxicos que ingresan las células y esto
se debe a una deficiencia de la
metilación del glutatión ya vamos a
hablar del rotación la oxidación de las
membranas también es importantes porque
en las membranas celulares es las que
van a permitir que entren los nutrientes
y que salgan los tóxicos y estas
membranas se pueden romper se pueden
recibir sal también se debe al daño del
dna que ya lo vamos a ver también o la
aplicación que sucede afuera de la
célula la aplicación sucede cuando
comemos azúcares y nuestras proteínas se
pegan generando fibrosa y los tejidos
entonces los radicales libres
qué son estos
no voy a entrar a explicarles la parte
química pero sí me interesa que se
queden con el efecto que generan los
radicales libres y estos pueden entonces
alterar las membranas rompiendo la
hablando de la muerte celular pueden
alterar las mitocondrias que obviamente
lamento con él es la productora de la
energía por lo tanto la energía baja y
la vitalidad de la persona va a bajar o
de los mismos tejidos y el daño en el
dinero
nuevamente la membrana celular con la
ruptura
daño en las mitocondrias esta es la
deficiencia de una proteína que protege
de la acumulación de hierro y se va a
destruir entonces la mitocondria
disminución de la energía y finalmente
el daño del dna
nuevamente el daño del dna porque quiero
que les quede claro que es donde aquí es
empieza el envejecimiento o las
patologías
nuevamente los radicales libres pueden
romper las cadenas de dna y que lo va a
proteger los antioxidantes
este es el daño que uno puede llegar que
son células tumorales de las células
hermosas que vimos esto es lo que se
puede llegar por el daño de la del dna
que necesita en nuestras células para
mantenerse sanos y como evitamos que se
dañen
primero las mitocondrias yo les hablé
que es la parte más importante porque es
el motor imagínense un auto si el auto
el motor se daña no va a funcionar como
auto porque no me va a poder transportar
lo mismo pasa la célula si el motor se
daña no van a poder generar energía los
células musculares o no van a poder
generar anticuerpos las células del
sistema inmunológico es cierto que van a
necesitar oxígeno necesitan además
macronutrientes y micronutrientes
por ejemplo para el metabolismo de la
grasa si comemos grasa necesitamos
magnesio y vamos a necesitar carnitina
si comemos hidratos de carbono vamos a
necesitar para metabolizar el liderazgo
carbón magnesio vitaminas del grupo b y
ácido alfa lipoico si comemos proteínas
necesitamos oxígeno y vamos a necesitar
zinc y para que exista el ciclo de la
energía formemos atp a necesitar
nuevamente el grupo ve hierro magnesio y
y manganeso si nosotros comemos y por
eso puse esto
una papa pelada que no tenga ninguna
vitamina nos vamos a empezar a consumir
los nutrientes y por eso que vamos a
generar daño celular
para que exista la energía necesitamos
nuevamente biotina todo el grupo b y
colina
la célula además necesita una enzima que
son las catalanas las super óxidos
mostaza y el glutatión para proteger la
célula de los radicales libres entonces
se produce en la mayoría en la
mitocondria por la mitad donde está
quemando utilizando el oxígeno y
produciendo peróxidos de oxígeno y
oxígeno reactivo entonces la super
opción mostaza necesita más manganeso
la catalana va a necesitar también la
célula vitamina a vitamina es cierto
vitamina c
y el glutatión que es muy importante
qué hace el glutatión el glutatión es la
molécula más importante para las células
porque es antioxidante también
desintoxica las células recupera la
vitamina c y la vitamina e regula el
acción nitroso que el óxido nitroso es
el que basso dilata los capilares
entonces de repente en algunos tejidos
cuando se habla de acidosis el acidosis
no es en la sangre en los tejidos y en
los tejidos por que el óxido nitroso
baja y no llega entonces el oxígeno al
tejido que nosotros queremos tratar
además de glutatión tiene que ver con la
recuperación de el adn cuando la arena
se daña lo va a recuperar
qué pasa lo que se ha visto en las
investigaciones es que el glutatión los
niveles va a bajar con la edad y se
relaciona con el estrés oxidativo
entonces la molécula más importante
relacionada con el estrés oxidativo
sería el glutatión
vamos a revisar ahora un poquito cuáles
son los parámetros para nosotros de
establecer que estamos envejeciendo
entonces los parámetros son por ejemplo
cambio físico cierto que vamos a ver acá
no es que vamos a ver arrugas que vamos
a ver flacidez se alarga la nariz
aumenta la circunferencia abdominal
disminuye la fuerza disminuye los
reflejos disminuye la visión y la
audición si uno fuera a hacer pruebas
metabólicas disminuye el consumo de
oxígeno y del metabolismo basal entonces
hay un test que nosotros hacemos que no
funciona bastante bien para evaluar el
metabolismo y para ver la composición
corporal además como cambias la
impedanciometría
hay bastantes biomarcadores para saber
cómo estamos envejeciendo y uno de los
más importantes que nosotros hacemos
el de micronutrientes con ese examen yo
puedo determinar qué nutriente estoy en
deficiencia y obviamente si me falta mis
células no van a ser capaces de producir
lo que el cuerpo necesita también hay
tests que nos dicen cómo está la
respuesta inmunológica toda la parte
hormonal es muy importante como les
decía porque además se puede reponer en
este minuto con hormonas bioidénticas en
esto es muy importante la hormona de
crecimiento el día
bueno los niveles de testosterona
extravió en melatonina cortisol y
progesterona
cuando nosotros respondemos estas
hormonas es muy importante porque las
personas pueden prevenir patologías
cuando las hormonas disminuyen por
ejemplo una cosa que va a aumentar los
niveles de corte de colesterol o sea a
través de mejorar las hormonas que la
persona se va a sentir mejor yo me puedo
ahorrar o mejorar el tratamiento de las
respuestas de los tratamientos de
colesterol
después hay tests genéticos que es muy
importante en chile hay algunos ya que
se pueden hacer
y esto es más importante para saber el
envejecimiento porque el otros son para
patología es la telomerasa además con
esto yo puedo saber puedo controlar por
ejemplo medir la telomerasa cómo está el
día de hoy hacer mi tratamiento con
antioxidantes o nutrientes y controlar
cómo ha mejorado
después hay biomarcadores digestivos
biomarcadores metabólicos
biomarcadores que son de inflamatorios
que son muy importantes para el
envejecimiento porque me va a permitir
establecer si yo tengo o no tengo
inflamación silente que también causa
deterioro y un envejecimiento acelerado
los digestivos y los metabólicos son
importantes para ellos estables para
prevenir patologías no tanto por el
envejecimiento sino para saber si estoy
haciendo alguna patología hay índices de
oxidación para saber el estrés oxidativo
y si yo tengo que trabajar con
antioxidantes y también hay índices
tóxicos que pueden ser los niveles de
homocisteína que mi cuerpo está siendo
incapaz de votarlos los tóxicos pueden
saber las acumulaciones de metales
pesados que pueden generar daño celular
y algunos efectos tóxicos en nuestro
organismo
stella impedanciometría que yo les
contaba es importante porque me va a
decir según la distribución del tejido
graso si yo tengo alguna alteración
hormonal y me va a determinar la masa
ósea muscular y grasa y la cantidad de
agua que también me puede decir cómo
estoy envejeciendo
él tiene micronutrientes va a decir por
ejemplo cualquier nutriente tengo y se
miden 31 compuesto
después tenemos los telómeros el
telómero es una estructura que está en
el adn que cuando se acorta se ha visto
que la célula envejece y obviamente si
está largo nos me está diciendo que no
estoy tan envejecido y se puede
establecer además si es correspondiente
a la edad
después que información actualizada de
la genética la genética se ha visto y
esto es bueno porque los genes no son
los que importan
o no nos van a determinar en sí una
patología sino es el medio que nosotros
vamos a trabajar que nos puede activar o
desactivar arguyen entonces eso se llama
epigenética la epigenética entonces es
la influencia que el medio le da a
alguien ya tenemos 100 trillones de
células y con 3 millones de pares del
núcleo tipo que significa que podríamos
la distancia a viajar 6 veces a la luna
y volver
hay estudios ya que sean determinados
genes y hay un gen que tiene que ver con
la longevidad y algunos otros están con
patologías
entonces la epigenética son determinada
por lo que vamos a comer y por qué es
porque se generan metabolitos que son
las histonas om o metilación es quien se
van a pegar al adn que van a hacer que
el adn se pliegue se enrolle y por lo
tanto no se expresen algunas moléculas
entonces ya a nivel internacional existe
un tipo de terapia que sería la
nutrigenómica que estudia los efectos de
los alimentos y la expresión genética
entonces si bien los gemelos son iguales
al nacer puede suceder esto ellas fueron
criadas en lugares distintos y expuestas
al ambiente distinto por lo tanto
intenta alimentación y dejan de verse
igual no otra cosa que se ha visto es
que el resveratrol va a activar un gen
que tiene que ver con el envejecimiento
longevo
y también la restricción calórica
entonces eso nos ayudaría a envejecer
mejor
y postres
que existió antes de cristo- médico y
era profesor
él ya decía que el alimento sea tu
medicina y tu medicina tu alimento y
como les decía no hay ni un medicamento
que logre recuperar el daño que se
genera
yo sé que es una lata la alimentación o
no les guste le encantaría que eligieran
hoy de 6 que comen lo que quieras va a
ser de joven siempre va a sentirte regio
pero no es así
entonces la dieta mediterránea está
estudiada que es la mejor de todas las
dietas ya se ha visto que regula también
a niveles de higienes en algunos en
algunas patologías como la diabetes esta
dieta demostró que ayuda a disminuir los
niveles de glicemia colesterol y el
riesgo de hacer patología cardiovascular
amigos la que recomiendo es una dieta de
mediterránea también que les dé doctor
sievers y además no es solamente la
calidad de la dieta sino un poquito las
cantidades de proteínas con hidratos
carbono y grasas que él me dio en sangre
y vio que la glicemia se mantenían
estables por los niveles de hormonas es
la única que está prueba científicamente
la alimentación que tenemos que cuidar y
donde parte cosas simples
tenemos que masticar bien porque el
masticar bien va a permitir que la
saliva que tiene la enzima latina que
ayuda a digerir los hidratos de carbono
solamente está en la saliva esto si
comemos hidrato carbono tenemos que
masticar lentamente y también nos va a
servir porque como la saliva es alcalina
nos va a alcanzar
entonces yo sé que la dieta alcalina
está muy de moda pero el cuerpo lo hace
solo solamente necesitamos masticar muy
bien tragar la saliva que es alcalina
tomar suficiente agua porque el riñón
también nos va a ayudar a votar
el exceso de hidrógeno y también tenemos
que respirar que también nos va a
alcanzar
entonces también va a ser importante los
nutrientes como ya les dije necesitamos
algunos nutrientes para poder
metabolizar los distintos alimentos va a
ser importante la que sea la proporción
adecuada que yo recomiendo el doctor
search a veces también importante es la
mezcla porque cuando uno come por
ejemplo proteínas o carne con papas a
veces no se digiere bien porque
mezclamos distintos partes y las enzimas
que digieren la proteína necesitan un ph
ácido distinto que los hidratos carbono
también hay que disfrutar o sea comer no
solamente tomar los nutrientes
es bueno dar las gracias en la medicina
ayurveda recomiendan dar las gracias y
hacerlo en un ambiente agradable tratar
de no comer apurado y lo otro importante
que hay que tener en cuenta la
alimentación es si ahí tenemos libios ya
si tenemos desvíos y por antibióticos o
porque los alimentos están viniendo con
antibióticos es bueno trabajar con
prebióticos y probióticos
entonces nuevamente el ph es muy
importante pero la verdad que el cuerpo
lo hace solo y solamente para
recordarles que los alimentos que son
procesados van a tender a generarnos
acidez y las frutas y verduras nos van a
alcalinizar pero
común y una voy a comer alguna de estas
cosas es bueno entonces incorporar a la
dieta y yo les digo a mis pacientes
bueno se va a comer hamburguesas bueno
agrega una fruta de postre cierto toma
agua porque obviamente si yo me tomo
cocacola más la hamburguesa estoy
generando mucho más acidez y se me
comieron las hamburguesas con agua o un
jugo de fruta pues son estrategias que
uno puede hacer para lograr una mejor
alimentación en los tiempos actuales el
agua es importante la mayoría de mis
pacientes me llegas hidratado porque es
porque no tenemos sed la sep no existe
solamente nos sentimos la sed cuando
estamos deshidratados qué signos vamos a
tener las ojeras marcadas vamos a tener
los dientes marcados en la lengua y se
nos va a ser un pliegue en la mano la
orina está más oscura entonces tratar de
fijarse si nos pasan esas cosas tomar
agua
también va a influir la calidad del agua
porque la calidad del agua hay aguas que
son más alcalinas y que son con
minerales es distinta que el agua que no
tiene minerales como el cuerpo necesita
para procesar los alimentos de mejor el
agua mineral ya antiguamente la gente
tomaba agua de manantiales y no el agua
purificada ahora es mejor el agua
purificada que el agua de la llave
porque el agua de la llave trae de sarro
y también bueno como decía registrar los
signos y los que nos están diciendo
estoy deshidratado porque no nos dan sed
otra cosa importante en la dieta estamos
comiendo pocos aminoácidos de los
aminoácidos que son esenciales para
tener la cantidad de glutatión que se
necesita en este momento que es
educación son es un tripe ppd y 2 son de
aminoácido necesitamos comer 2000 gramos
de proteínas entonces es imposible
entonces algunas hay algunas cosas que
vamos a tener que suplementar y también
estamos consumiendo pocas vitaminas y
pocos minerales tratar de bajar los
tóxicos porque mientras más tóxicos
estoy expuesto más glutatión necesito y
como les decía no hay que suplementar lo
porque a través de la dieta no se puede
entonces tanto los tóxicos de del
ambiente la radiación los rayos uv del
estrés los pesticidas la contaminación
atmosférica el humo de tabaco los
metales pesados grasas saturadas y
también considerar que está aumentando
los campos electromagnéticos con los
wifi celulares computadores mis
pacientes que más oxidación tienen son
los que están expuestos a los campos
electromagnéticos entonces tenerlos
considerado
nuestro cuerpo tiene la capacidad de
desintoxicarse es mejor que el auto
usted el auto le tiran barro tienen que
lavarlo el cuerpo tiene la capacidad de
eliminar si se si se ensucia con barro
sólo porque tiene a través del monitoreo
que es el colon el hígado el pulmón el
riñón y la piel tienen la capacidad de
eliminar este barro problemas que si le
estamos barro en la mañana al almuerzo
de la tarde saturamos sus sistemas
entonces exceso de tóxicos no le permite
a nuestro cuerpo desintoxicarse si nos
fallan los nutrientes tampoco y si nos
falta agua
y también
entonces cuál es el enfoque integral
para envejecer bien
chequear parámetros podemos ver los
marcadores si queremos ser más
específicos pero necesitamos suplementar
las hormonas porque las hormonas
disminuyen necesitamos suplementar
prebióticos y probióticos antioxidantes
y nutrientes
una cosa que no existe la medicina
tradicional es las terapias de
desintoxicación que son muy útiles de
qué se trata una desintoxicación por
ejemplo es tomar agua verduras y frutas
y pues como una alimenta a un bebé
que le da reposo intestinal y muy útil
es conocer nuestra genética
como les contaba la terapia hormonal
existe es muy útil la terapia
antioxidante tenerla muy en cuenta
de suplementación que son fundamentales
también se sabe la meditación esto
normalmente no lo sabe nadie y no se usa
tampoco porque la gente le da más
interés al ejercicio pero a mí tensión
está siendo una herramienta maravillosa
porque ya se está determinando a nivel
de sangre en meditación sube las células
madres a la sangre pero también se ha
visto que participan en las
la mitación disminuyen los genes que
participan en la inflamación y también
disminuye de algunos genes que van a
relacionarse con histonas que yo les
decía que activan los genes para generar
algunas patologías mensaje de hoy
podemos envejecer bien espero sigan
investigando y participen también en la
investigación
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]